the times are changing far faster than  they ever were before and that requires  a new kind of thinking elastic thing  [Music]  yeah so I guess you would just come from  being like well this has been useful  could we survive without rulers without  this date what is truth why do we  believe the things we do whom did we  believe and why reading about quantum  physics has really helped me understand  my queer identity news seems to lead  weird shades of pink of multiple shades  of beige and in my humble opinion  mainstream fashion brands still make  women of color feel invisible the more  you're exposed to what other people  think the broader your own thinking will  be help there you go that would be  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Music]